Her low freak bitches and I attributed it to cutting out refined sugars and
refined carbohydrates.
I think,
I think that stuff's poison,
but there's been studies showing it also affects your brain and negative way as
well.
And people that eat refined sugar,
you know,
there's,
there's more brain atrophy.
I mean there's lots of correlations.
The one thing I will say is that,
you know,
there are people that are super physically active and they're like working out
two hours a day and you know,
those guys,
they'll use refined sugar yeah.
To,
you know,
their,
their increased transport glucose transporter in their muscles and you're using
it as an anabolic way to like get bigger muscle.
And I know guys who do that after they work out the candy.
Yeah.
And,
and it,
it's not like it's,
it's,
you can't compare like people that aren't working out like two hours a day or
two to normal people as Freeman sedentary people,
weight lifters.
Yeah.
Weightlifters he pulled it are just ripping their body apart.
There's a lot of savages out there that are doing crazy power lifting workouts
and benching and squatting.
And I know a lot of guys who like to eat candy afterwards.
Right?
Yeah.
No,
it's,
it's certainly,
you know,
I think that those people,
they're,
they're not,
it's not,
it's not acting the same way.
It's radically different requirement that their body needs in terms of glucose.
And,
and the thing is,
I mean,
still,
it's like,
the way I think about it is it's not really nutrient dense.
You know,
I like to like,
I'm like,
well,
there's lots of,
there's a reason.
Yeah,
there's a reason why I like to like take and if you want the sugar and then,
you know,
I wouldn't get an orange or an apple or something like that,
you should probably the better move than eating candy.
But I think they just want a ton of it.
And what is the,
what's the anabolic factor?
Look,
if you were going to eat candy or something like that,
has a bunch of refined sugar after like an intense workout.
What would be the antibiotic factor?
Well,
the glucose,
so the,
the workout causes,
um,
Glucose transporters that transport glucose to like go through the roof.
And so you start the glucose from your bloodstream gets like sucked into the
muscle and then in the muscle,
you know,
you're,
you're basically,
you can,
you can use that as,
as,
as a way to,
to,
to have insulin and it can be anabolic,
right?
Where,
where,
whereas if you weren't doing that,
then the glucose in your bloodstream and it can all sorts of small dense LDL
particles can start to form because the inflammatory transformations that happen
and things like that.
Um,
that's at least my understanding that's in combination of course with,
um,
I mean,
oh,
acids,
which are also important for the growth of the protein and muscle.
But that's my understanding of it.
I think.
So like in general though,
if someone could cut one thing out of their diet,
refined carbohydrates and refined sugars would be a great way to go.
I think the one,
if you were to think about the one easiest thing that you could do that would
have the biggest impact on your health,
and if we're talking,
if we're talking about,
we're not talking about someone who's already Paleo or someone like you or I
were talking about like standard American person.
Yes.
The one thing that they could do to have the biggest impact on their health I
would say is to cut out refined sugar.
Like that's,
that's probably the biggest thing.
The easiest thing,
I mean I don't know how easy it is.
It,
you know,
it can be addicting.
Yeah.
And that's been shown dopamine levels,
you know,
can get activated.
Game B was basically proceeded from the idea that what we live in is a game
theoretic landscape,
right.
That the winners in this game theoretic landscape are individuals who have
figured out where there's a niche.
Some of them have figured out how to engage in something called rent seeking,
which rent seeking basically means making money without producing some without
producing value.
So there's a lot of stuff that goes on in our economy that is not productive.
And good,
but nonetheless generates fortunes.
So that's rent seeking as opposed to innovation or productivity.
You're talking about like hedge fund type stuff,
moving money around.
Well,
I want to be a little careful about this because it is quite possible for things
like hedge funds to actually correct inefficiencies in the economy in a way that
is productive.
That doesn't mean that that's the average thing that,
so do things are you referring to?
Well,
I mean,
you know,
let's,
let's take the,
the ultimate example that will make it clear.
A warlord is not responsible for,
um,
for building the road that they then stand by the side of and extort money from
people who want to travel it.
A cable company may produce some benefit.
They obviously have infrastructure that allows you to get content,
but what fraction of what you're paying for is actually about them delivering a
service at some price and making some reasonable profit.
And what fraction of it is about the fact that they are an economic Goliath and
that you don't have enough choice to be able to negotiate a decent price with
them?
So there's some fraction of what they're producing that is productive,
but then there's a large amount of profit there that isn't about productivity or
innovation.
It's about the fact that they own a choke point and you can't get around it.
Um,
so we don't know what fraction of the economy is a rent seeking and what
fraction of it is productive.
But there is,
especially if one is broad minded about thinking about all the ways that one can
engage in rent seeking,
one can actually be destructive of value.
If you destroy future wellbeing for our descendants,
it may look productive in the present,
but it isn't productive.
It's actually destructive.
So that's a kind of um,
rent seeking that we don't even typically model.
But,
uh,
we're,
where are we headed?
So,
Oh yes.
So we live in a game theoretic landscape that's both good and bad.
As you point out,
competition is a healthy thing and competition in markets produces a huge amount
of value.
So I hear people deriding capitalism and I always want to make the same point to
them,
which is you've got two things glued together and you are challenging them as a
package,
but there's no reason they have to be packaged.
So we would be foolish to give up markets.
Markets are amazingly powerful engines of innovation.
They are capable of solving problems that we cannot solve deliberately,
even if we want it to.
So we need markets,
but we don't want markets ruling the planet and deciding that anything that
spits out a profit is therefore good and that we should be exposed to whatever
the market discovers can be a viable.
So what we want is ultimately to provide,
um,
provide incentive structures that cause the market to produce things that are
good for us,
right?
In other words,
if you tell the market that you want the solution to some problem,
the market can figure out how to solve that problem and it will do it very well.
But if you allow the market to decide what problems to solve,
it may end up,
for example,
addicting you to your phone,
right addicting to you.
To your phone in a way that harms your social relationships,
harms your,
your parenting of your children,
harms all kinds of things that are really important,
breaks the ability of your children to have a educational experience in school.
We don't want the market discovering how to disrupt useful functioning of
people.
We want the market to stay out of that stuff and then to provide us benefits
that,
uh,
only it can provide,
like all of the mechanisms that now allow us to navigate seamlessly in places
that we've never been avoiding traffic that we wouldn't know to worry about.
Right?
Those are huge benefits and they're capable of taking a city that is to snarled
with traffic and reducing the degree to which it is snarled with traffic.
So they're very powerful,
but we shouldn't,
we shouldn't throw the baby out with the bath.
Water markets are good.
Allowing markets to discover any and every,
uh,
mechanism for exploiting you is not good at all.
And in fact,
it's a large part of why we're in the predicament that we're in,
is that we let the market decide what problems to solve.
Okay.